all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
let's go next to alexander from
something that starts with p-a-l i can't
it's cut off where are you from
alexander
um
[Music]
um
i'm from a town called palm coast
okay palm coast
what's on your mind today
it's in florida gotcha
and by the way i've never been on the
air before so i'm kind of nervous oh
don't worry you're doing great what's on
your mind
hey um
i wanted to come to ask you something
see if you could personally um
answer this um
um
you know
it's about these news
networks that everyone talks about yeah
what's the difference between fox news
newsmax and oan also known as one
america news well i think they become
more reactionary in exactly the order
you listed them fox newsmax oan in that
order
what do you mean reactionary more
unhinged extreme and uh cartoonish i
guess i would say like
oan to me seems like it's out and out
crazy where there's people on it
like for example the anti-vaxx stuff on
fox
is a little more polished it's less
polished on newsmax and it's straight up
crazy on oan like i think i think that
that's that am i getting my point across
um
i think so she's i i never really viewed
them as that and i'm i have a hard time
really distinguishing them oh okay yeah
i mean listen i will i will admit
that fox has done stuff in the last
three months on tucker's show for
example related to vaccines where tucker
says you know tens of thousands of
people
appear to have died from the vaccine a
statement that's totally untrue that has
even surprised me
but as a general thing i find that
newsmax is crazier than fox and oan is
even crazier with even lower
journalistic standards to the extent
that they exist like i don't even think
newsmax has any of what they even
pretend is hard news whereas fox does
but it's biased you know
yeah i guess so i just
i don't know i i never really thought of
it like that because
i knew they were all kind of people
would like lump them in the same
category but i didn't know like they
were like
that different from each other and how
they report on news and yeah they're
they're definitely in the same category
but i think oan is uh is is the absolute
crazy like you mean like fox news is the
quote-unquote my oldest and then uh one
america news is like the most unhinged
the most
off the walls
bonkers
news channel that's how i would put it
yeah hey alexander i know you said
you're you're in florida are you from
new york originally
what the
sorry what
so i said what the because my whole
family is oh okay yeah no you just have
a very noticeable new york accent and
you sound like michael cohen you know
really yeah now
that's interesting to know um
um i'm pretty sure that was it
actually uh uh this i'm gonna make this
very very quick
but there's one more thing
that i feel like i need to ask okay um
so
you hear about um
[Music]
what's it called it's the thing with the
um
alexander i've got a lot of people
holding so i'm gonna let you go i really
appreciate the call and the multiple
questions and it's been a true pleasure
having you on
let me go next to steve from chicago
illinois steve how are you
i'm doing good how are you i'm doing
well sorry
what's on your mind no i asked you it's
okay
uh there's a reactionary um
uh i had a couple things you can cut me
off i'm going for too long though sure
um quick question um i know you did a
video on
um anti-semitism with tucker and i think
he was talking to godfeld yep um with
george soros um i i felt like you were
just kind of saying it was anti-semitic
for
saying stuff they didn't like what
george soros was doing i don't know if
you can explain it a little better it
kind of seemed like
they
were kind of like just like talking
about how he uses money and then
that's like anti-semitic nope that's not
at all it's definitely not what i said
and it's also not what i meant so i'm
glad to have the opportunity to say more
um george soros at this point is
basically a placeholder boogeyman
for is it boogeyman or bogeyman i am not
actually do you know which it is
it's bogeyman boogeyman okay george
soros has become a sort of anti-semitic
placeholder boogeyman
for um uh for code
for rich jews in many cases and so
whether tucker specifically intended it
to be that or not um
the the soros ruining america with his
money is just a tired anti-semitic trope
which which makes no sense i mean he's a
91 year old guy at this point and the
idea that he would be hell bent on
destroying america in any way
simply doesn't pass the sniff test and
so you really have to look at context
and
everything about
that piece
reeked of the sort of let's find someone
to blame and we're not going to mention
that he's jewish but it's this this
trope of the rich jew
ruining and controlling things for his
benefit it's just a very old trope it
doesn't mean what tucker was
specifically saying is anti-semitic
okay i mean um i guess i can kind of see
what you were saying i guess i just i
don't think that segment was
too anti-semitic and i was no no and
that's the thing is you have to under
that it's by design that
if
it coded language and coded tropes are
designed where if you don't know the
milieu within which it exists you
wouldn't see it for what it is a part of
i i get the coded language i just don't
think they're like using coding language
in that scenario there
for there i guess i just disagree with
you on that yes i don't mean literally
language
literally anti-semitic okay
what i guess would be what whoopi
goldberg said this week on the view i
don't know if you've been able to touch
that or not yep i think what whoopi
goldberg says is this said was
disgusting and it unfortunately plays
into so
the george soro stuff
is the type of anti-semitism you see
from the right the whoopee stuff about
the holocaust wasn't about race
and a jew you know it goes to the jews
are not an oppressed minority
soft anti-semitism that's more common on
the left so i called it out on the
wednesday show absolutely
oh i'm sorry i must i must have missed i
was just wondering no that's cool um
about that and uh if you can call me you
can call me off if you want but the last
question i had was i know i've seen some
stuff on you on uh gerrymandering from
the right i was wondering if you had any
comment on what's been going on what
they're proposing for new york which
seems very ex uh
on the side of gerrymandering extreme
for restriction
my view my view on this is not partisan
my view on this is gerrymandering is bad
and we need a system
that is a non-partisan system there's
four or five different ones that have
been proposed i'm agnostic about which
as long as it's better than what we have
now
and i also recognize that for as long as
gerrymandering is possible if
republicans are going to do it as badly
as they can i have to also recognize
that democrats must take opportunities
to do it because otherwise they lose
everything
all right um i guess i can see that is i
guess it just probably won't ever stop
then if both sides can keep on doing it
then well remember the mechanism to stop
the gerrymandering is a different one
than the mechanism by which
gerrymandering takes place so you can
both realize
that if either they gerrymander or we do
it's better if it's us you can recognize
that and at the same time work to put in
place a nonpartisan redistricting
commission you can do both
um yeah i guess like i don't know two
evils don't make a right uh in my mind i
agree and i'm not saying for the power
yeah um but i appreciate you taking my
call and answering the questions and
kind of giving me more of an outlook of
what you're saying with the whole uh
soros um aspect on that thank you very
much all right thank you steve very much
appreciate it great uh great to hear
from you